last week an inquest found francis quinn  father hugh mullen noel phillips  joan connolly daniel teget  joseph murphy edward doherty  john lavity joseph core  and john mccur who were killed in valley  murphy  in 71 entirely innocent  on behalf of successive governments and  to put on the record in this house i  would like  to say sorry to their families for how  the investigations  were handled and for the pain they've  endured since their campaign began  almost five decades ago  no apology mr speaker can lessen their  lasting pain  i hope they may take some comfort in the  answers they have secured  and in knowing that this has renewed the  government's determination to ensure  in future that other families can find  answers with less  distress and delay